the pentagon isn't just trying to purge
trump supporters from its ranks
it's also brainwashing the next
generation of officers
to essentially be marxist blm type
agitators now
the latest example comes from west point
this is our country's oldest service
academy
now according to a recent letter from
florida congressman mike waltz a former
greenberry himself
west point cadets have been forced to
attend critical
race theory seminars in one session from
last year white police officers
were described as murderers slides from
another seminar included the titles
white power
at west point and racist dog whistles
at west point here to react is west
point grad
jeremy hunt jeremy i had a chance uh
today to talk to a few other
uh of uh your old colleagues at west
point
and they could not believe
what i told them they were infuriated
demoralized
but i'd say it uh it leaned more toward
being infuriated your reaction tonight
yeah i mean this is unlike anything that
i ever saw when i was at the academy and
that was just six years ago i mean i you
know when i when i decided to go to west
point
i wanted to go because i wanted to learn
about service about leadership
i didn't want to go to another woke
indoctrination camp
like some of our other college
universities uh and i and i think this
is really going to backfire with
recruitment because a lot of people
especially young high schoolers
want a unique experience they don't want
to get just the typical college
experience where everything's about race
and
identity politics but west point stands
for something different
and that's the experience that i think
that the academy is standing to lose
with
if you infuse it with this critical race
theory stuff
uh and i'm just i'm concerned about my
alma mater when we think about
the challenges we face on the on the
global stage
most notably from china what do you
think they're thinking like wait a
second
their fighting force is spending time in
this
perpetual state of self-loathing it's
not be
all that you can be it's be as
as sorrowful as you can about just how
rotten the country is
that you've sworn to defend
that's exactly right and what makes it
even worse is that
the biden harris administration this is
very strategic
they have specifically chosen west point
because it's our premier military
academy and they're hoping this idea
will spread throughout the force
so it's not even going to just stay at
west point i mean they're training a lot
of young
officers to lead soldiers and they want
this critical race theory
thinking to kind of metastasize
throughout the military i have to share
this with the audience and you
now pbs reported on the military's
so-called
anti-extremism training and what it
looks like
watch reason we're doing this training
is first to define it
why we're doing it what's the cause of
it how many of you know
what pepe the frog stands for or 88.
pepe the frog was just the internet meme
that they utilized
you know i think like the proud boys
utilize pepe the frog memes just to
make a dog whistle jokes towards the
left
and 88 would stand for hh hale hitler
other right wing connotations honestly
watching that video i'm learning new
things about some of this extremist
ideology
about it the more we kind of talk about
it and make it sound like this is
the dominant uh ideology in our country
now we're actually spreading it and
we're spreading the hate we're spreading
the
the the kind of evil thinking behind a
lot of that radical
uh white supremacist stuff uh but and
that's honestly the problem is and we're
also distracted from the mission
we're distracted from actually
accomplishing carrying out our our
country's strategic goals abroad
and we are also tearing away the fra the
fabric of
teamwork and that that's so important
especially jeremy we're
having a laughingstock i'm going to say
it simply we look
like a laughingstock we've taken the
greatest fighting force
on the face of the earth and we're
trying to turn them into like these
thursday night
seminar attendees at some you know woke
ivy league institution
jeremy uh you're the best guest to have
on tonight thank you so much
thank you